[Music]
one of the biggest categories of the
night Outstanding Comedy Series this is
going to be such a tough category
because we've got Atlanta blackish
master of none
Modern Family Silicon Valley unbreakable
kimmy schmitt and V what's amazing is
this is the first year that three shows
feature predominantly non-white casts
which is a huge feat I think but of
course modern family who has won this
category six times excuse me
five times if they win this year for the
sixth time they'll be the only comedy
series to collect that trophy for the
big award six times they're currently
tied right now five and five with
Frasier and if they beat it then this is
gonna be such a huge deal but I will say
if modern family wins I will be so upset
the other time they've had their time in
the Sun it's time for a new show to step
into the spotlight I personally want it
to be Atlanta I think that that is such
a fantastic show Donald Glover deserves
this he's not only starring in he's also
an executive producer so he would be
getting double accolades for this but
who I you think will win is V they're
the reigning champion one last year
given the political climate I feel like
that sits on a lot of people's minds a
lot of voters Minds it could be it could
be
[Music]
you